Okay, so I'm going to go over the
difference between a developing profile
and an area that is already established
value or established profile, right? So,
um
not to say you can't trade from a
developing profile. My personal trading,
I I don't do that.
Um but it's a really common thing that I
see people struggle with over time. So,
this is a really common setup you see
somebody using. This is just a session
volume profile on TradingView, right?
I'm looking at Bitcoin, but you can look
at any other market you want. Uh and
what we're going to talk about today
applies to volume profile, applies to
TPO, it doesn't matter.
Uh so firstly, when it comes to trading
profiles, there's a few things you need
to ask yourself. One,
is the market balanced or is it
imbalanced, right? So, if we're looking
at a balanced market, we're seeing,
you know, two-sided trading, right?
Consolidation, right? You get a break
from balance, this is now an imbalanced
market. So, in regards to trading
profiles,
um
if if volume or or if time is not evenly
distributed, profiles are much less
applicable to your kind of trading. So,
we talk about trading balance and
imbalance.
Uh balance is where, you know, if you
identify balance, then you can plot a
profile on it and get your area of
value, right? So, first thing, is the
market balanced or is it imbalanced?
Secondly,
do we have an area of established value
or are we trying to trade developing
value, right? So,
if you are to look,
>> [clears throat]
>> you know, at any of these profiles,
right? You ever think kind of how they
came to be, right? So, you know, I'm on
TradingView uh rewind here. So, if we
were to go back to,
let's say here at the start of this day,
right? It might take a second for this
to load. All right, but like I said,
firstly,
is you know, are we balanced, are we
imbalanced, right? So, the problem is,
you know, how did this come to be? The
reason I know this is balanced here is
because, you know, it's established, we
broke from balance. I now know that this
is an established area of balance. Like
I said, when we when we identify
balance, you can then plot something on
it to get value, being a profile.
Um but let's disregard that for now.
So, firstly, this day in isolation, is
this very usable? Not really be just
because of how these profiles overlap.
So that's where you could use a fixed
range volume profile, let's say. So
being how the prior day ends here,
right, measuring a good bulk of this
balance area, and then part of this day
measures the rest of it, then it goes in
balance down, right? And then the day
ends here. So that is one of the issues
with using a time base profile as you
have to have a bit of discretion um
about how you go about using them,
right? So this is going to measure a day
regardless.
Whereas if you were using a TPO, you
could split the profile here, or if
you're using a fixed range volume
profile, it's a two-click tool, then you
can realize, you know, you can identify
that okay, balance starts here and it
ends here, right? So now this is the
area I want to be working with, right?
Which we'll get to that. But
nonetheless,
uh question to ask yourself, is this
profile evenly distributed? The question
the answer is no,
right? You have balance here, which it's
measuring part of it, and then you have
some balance that's seemingly forming
here. So the value area on this isn't
skewed. Really what you have is value
built here, and you have value built
here, right?
So anyways, let's go along with kind of
how the day would develop following
this, the the new day, right?
Let's see, we open.
You can see that price continues to
trade.
Right? It continues to develop, right?
You can see value is developing, right?
So the issue is, right? Like I said, so
is is, you know, is price normally
distributed up to this point? The answer
is yes. This is a normal distribution.
We talk about distributions, right?
You're looking for that nice bell shape
where
you know, this is a balanced profile,
right? Your point of control is
somewhere around the middle of the
distribution, where the most value, or
sorry, most volume, or most time is
spent uh as it tapers off towards the
edges of the profile, right? This is
where, you know, your value area and
high would would rest around here, okay?
Um the issue with trading a developing
profile is that you have no defined
levels up to this point with what's
actually happening, right?
Um from here, I would say we did build
out balance, and we've now broke above.
This is evenly distributed, right? But
like I said, if it's not evenly
distributed, what's to say we don't do
this and this and this, and then, you
know, like up to that point, value now
migrates higher. So, the issue with
trading
a developing profile is your levels
aren't clearly defined due to the fact
that it's continuing to develop, right?
So,
if we break from this area of balance,
right?
This should now hold going forward if
it's going to trade up, okay?
If it doesn't, then expect a reversion
back down to the lows. So, if we
continue to play this forward, we can
just see what develops.
Right?
You can see that those levels ultimately
we kind of held this this level, but
again, value is still developing.
So, you don't have clearly defined
levels. Now you do, right? So, like I
said,
now we have this prior day.
Is it normally distributed?
The answer is yes,
right? So, these levels are now clearly
defined. Going forward, this should hold
on a retest, right? We've now seemingly
found acceptance above value area high
is now flipped to support. We should
continue to trend going forward, right?
If this now fails, you should expect
acceptance and expect Sorry, expect a
rotation to the other side of value,
right?
Like I said, the issue with trading a
developing profile is you need to ask
yourself a couple questions. One, is it
evenly distributed? Two,
uh are we in a balanced market? Are we
in an imbalanced market? Three, you
know, how long has this profile actually
been developing for? Are we 3 hours into
the session? Are we 20 hours into this
into the day, right? So, these are
questions you need to ask yourself.
So, going forward, right?
This should now hold, right? This should
now hold as support, being that this is
now clearly defined. This is an area of
prior value that's become established.
So, the big takeaway is that you should
care more about trading from areas of
prior established value as opposed to
the current developing profile. Not to
say there can't be trades had. I'm not
looking for a fight with anybody here.
I'm simply saying that that is how I
trade. And your levels are very much
clearly defined. Of course, there's
times when they become less important,
more important, right? A more recent
profile is going to
uh be more relevant to the current
auction, of course, as opposed to a
profile from 3 weeks ago, let's say.
Um but the point is your levels are
clearly defined, right? So,
if we were to go back, right?
You know, breaking from value here, if
we're going to continue to trade up to
prior balance, right? Being the market
is is seeking fair value and the market
goes from a balanced state to an
imbalanced state and usually will will
go and seek areas of prior balance like
this, right? What we can do, given how,
like I said, this this day's profile
terminates here, and then this day ends
here, it's not actually getting a proper
calculation of of value here because,
like I said, we're measuring balance
here. Some of this balance, this profile
dips into some of this balance. So, what
you can do instead, if you're to use a
volume profile, is is use a fixed range,
right? So, you can click it all the way
to where uh price broke from balance.
So, now you have very clearly defined
levels. So, if we look,
here's value area low, point of control,
value area high. Right? So, if I put a
box on this just for simplicity's sake,
this is now your value area based on
this area of balance, okay? So, going
forward,
this should hold.
This should be resistance, right? But
the the conditions now bullish cuz we
held above here. So, let's see what
happens, right? This profile in itself
is not usable. The developing day to me
is completely useless right now. This is
where we should hold. This is the
destination. Should be find acceptance
above here, right? And hold, this could
potentially be a long up towards the
point of control and other side of
value, which is also confluent with the
prior day value area low. Right? So,
let's just see what happens. Just delete
these.
We need to trade up. It might take a
while, but going forward, like I said,
this should hold.
It's building out some balance, but,
like I said, in isolation, there's not
much to do with it, okay?
Again, it continues to hold, right?
Price swept those lows,
did not find acceptance back inside of
value, and now we've you know, we've
traded into
this prior area of balance. So, going
forward, this kind of area should hold,
right? We've already traded up into the
point of control, right? So, if you were
long here, of course, I'm on the
30-minute timeframe, that's a good first
target. Maybe we we see the full move
through value.
Okay, but again, you see how useless
this profile is as it develops.
Right?
That's why we care about areas of
established value.
I mean, retesting the edge, assuming
this kind of failed, right? We're
filling the imbalance. Let's just see,
maybe it trades up, but the POC
interrupted the move through value,
which can happen.
So, let's just see if it is able to
trade back in.
Okay? That's a pretty aggressive move,
and then from there, we'd probably see
the move all the way through value.
Maybe we get one more retest, I'm not
sure.
There's your retest, and I would be
looking to trade that up now.
So, it failed, right?
Um but again, the point of control can
interrupt the move, and then at that
point, right, you now have new balance
to work with. So, the point is
again, I'm running through raw examples
here. I don't I don't cherry-pick what
I'm trying to show here, right? The fact
of the matter is areas of prior
established value are are going to be
much clearly are much more clearly
traded, right?
And something is developing, you don't
have
levels to work with that you can
um
you know, confidently say that you know,
they're going to hold, right? As value
continues to develop, you don't know.
So, first thing to ask yourself
is value normally distributed?
Firstly,
secondly,
um is the market imbalanced or
balanced?
Right? First thing kind of tell
yourself, is value normally distributed?
So, for example, a profile like this, it
is normally distributed. Is the market
imbalanced or balanced? Right? Balanced
state, imbalanced state, right? Where is
value being built? Right? How can I
capitalize on these trades? Right? So,
now, right? Being that price has found
acceptance,
you know, back below into this prior
profile, it's also broken down from this
fixed range profile here, and it's
uh traversed value right now. We're back
down to VAL. So, seemingly this will be
resistance
until it's not. This will be support
until it's not, right?
So, we broke down, right? Again, this
overlap here between VAL and value high,
and then now that actually propelled the
move up to
value high here.
Right?
And then just becomes rotational from
there, right? So, now, value high is
resistance, value low support. It will
continue to do that until a directional
break happens.
Right?
So, like that one there.
All right, guys. So, hopefully that was
useful. It's just a really common thing
I see, you know,
people running into
um
trying to trade the current developing
day's profile. Not to say it's useless,
again, it just you know, your levels
aren't clearly defined. This is
personally how I like to trade things.
Cheers.